hey i've seen plenty of your videos and
i love the teachings you have i'm just
wondering as a 28 year old who's always
been timid about expressing my personal
feeling in the workplace to my bosses
what's the best way to overcome that
especially when you were taught to
always respect the people above you
beautiful question i think respecting
your elders is a tremendous attribute
and one that i admire and one that i
play quite a bit i really do think it's
a fear thing there's absolutely a
respectful way to say hey i'm unhappy or
hey i don't think that was done well or
hey have you thought about
and
you've got an ideology of like respect
your elders but it's conformed into a
fear it's mixed with fear
fear is the great poison of our society
respecting your elders is beautiful
being in a place where fear is dictating
your actions is a vulnerability so i
think you just got to jump into water
many of these things are like kissing
the boy or girl swimming or riding a
bike things that are so scary in your
own mind until you actually do them